朋友們今天這期視頻真的是太硬核了我跟你們說我準備的時候就感覺那種各種知識點想法就突突突突的往外冒準備好了嗎朋友們咱們今天就來聊一聊做空說到做空我們就會感覺在金融市場上都玩的可歡了就比如說電影《大空頭》裡邊有做空刺激債滾水做空瑞幸咖啡中蓋索羅斯做空英鎊然後還有去年華爾街大戰韭菜各種做空的等等等等
所以今天小玲就準備結合這些588們的經典案例，當然裡面有成功的也有失敗的，咱們就一起來把整個邏輯線條捋一捋，講一講做空到底是什麼，有哪些千奇百怪的玩法，還有它為什麼不像你想像的那麼簡單。這個時間點適合點個贊哦。
做空的概念其實並不難理解如果朋友你知道它是什麼意思可以跳過這一攀其實你看一般情況下如果我們想做投資如果你看好了一個股票或者一個期貨你預期它會漲那你就買入對吧等它漲了你就賣出從中間賺一筆這個就叫買入叫做多也叫落那我們知道金融這些產品它可能會漲就可能會跌那如果我預期一個股票它會跌那我能從裡邊賺錢嗎其實很簡單你就調換一下順序對吧我先把它賣掉等這個股票跌了我再給它買進來
從中間又轉一筆。這個就是做空，short selling。當然有些人可能會分的比較細，做空和賣空還要再做區分，大多數情況下這都是混著用的，所以我們今天就混著用。有人就問了，做空要先賣後買，那我沒有股票怎麼辦，那我怎麼賣呢？問到點上了，這時候你就要先去找一個人把這股票借進來，借進來之後把它賣掉，等它跌了再把它買回來，買完再還回去。舉個例子，比如說你現在看跌一個股票，老王奶茶店，這肯定不是小林奶茶店了。
老王奶茶店現在100塊錢但是你覺得它不行它肯定要跌所以這時候你就想做空它但是你手裡又沒有老王奶茶店的股票這時候怎麼辦呢？你看隔壁有個老李他手裡有老王奶茶店的股票你就跟他說李哥你這股票能不能借給我？李哥把股票借給你了你把股票賣掉這時候你手裡不是拿了100塊錢嗎？沒過兩天果然如你所料假設這股票
跌到50了這時候你把它買回來對吧你其實只花了50塊錢那手裡剩的這50塊錢相當於你自己賺瞭然後你買回來股票之後呢再把它還給老李物歸原主這樣對老李來說其實他也沒什麼損失反正他長期也是要持有老王奶茶店這個股票但是對你來講你就賺了50塊錢
所以這個就是做空股票一個最基本的流程就是先借進來把它賣出買回來再還回去賺錢你看這個流程很簡單但我們再稍微深入一點這裡面有兩個問題你看你是不是也有類似的疑問第一你說像老李這種人你上哪去找去你怎麼知道誰收了有老王奶茶店的股票對吧第二就算你找到了老李老李他憑什麼要把股票借給你
來咱們來說一下第一個問題你上哪找老李這時候你就需要一個中介一般來講你就可以找到證券公司因為證券公司很多人在他們開戶他就知道誰有老王奶茶店的股票就可以幫你找到這些有意願借出股票的老李當然如果你是一個很大的機構做空投資者這時候就可以有投行來服務你投行裡面有專門的一個部門叫做Prime brokerage他就是負責幫你找老李的
好，第二個問題，你說人家股東為什麼平白無故會把股票借給你？那當然不是平白無故的了，我們知道在金融市場裡你借錢肯定也是要付利息的，借股票一樣你也得付利息啊，這個我們之後再細說。所以簡單來說，理論上講，做空其實就是做多的一個反向操作，一個希望股票漲，一個希望股票跌，僅此而已。
我跟你說一般人要講做空可能講到這兒就到此為止了那你看看咱們的進度條才剛到那兒有趣的地方才剛剛開始咱們就來看看真實世界裡的做空它到底是什麼樣子
首先啊 咱剛剛不是說做空是這個股票越跌你越賺錢嗎假設剛才老王奶茶店是一百塊錢它頂大天跌到零就是破產了你也就賺一百塊錢但是反過來假設有一天老王奶茶店發布了一個重大的利好消息比如他跟小雷奶茶店合作了那這股票就嗖嗖嗖往上漲漲到兩百三百四百那這時候你就虧一百兩百三百它漲的越多你虧的越慘這時候你這頭髮就滑滑滑的開始往下掉而且這個是無極限的這個就是做空的第一大特點就是你將面臨的是有限的收益
和什麼呢？哎對了，無限的損失。
這個事放在理論模型裡可能沒啥它就是一個收益函數分佈的一個特徵但是放到現實裡它就會導致基金經理掉頭髮因為你做空要面臨的就是無限的損失所以你作為一個長期做空的基金經理就是要面臨這個焦慮你經常看到一個股票一年之內就翻好幾倍的情況咱都不說個股就每股大盤從2020年的3月到2022年就整整翻了一倍大盤都翻了一倍你就說這做空機構的日子它得多不好過
我們之前不是講過有一個安然財務造假的例子嗎？其實在基金圈裡有一個特別有名的做空大佬叫做Jim Chanos當時在2001年的時候他就自己分析發現了安然的財務有問題就大舉做空安然從這一個案子裡面就賺了5億美金一舉成名
之後他又成功做空了瑞幸咖啡，還有德國一個公司Wirecard,也是涉及到金融騙局。還有就是美國有一個租車的公司，後來也倒閉了，叫Hertz。你看是不是挺厲害的，也給一個準。但是啊，再厲害的大佬都有犯錯誤的時候。而且我們剛剛說做空他面臨的是無限的損失。就比如2016年的時候，Chanos經過他一番嚴密的分析，瞄準了一個做空對象，特斯拉。
他一進行基本面分析發現特斯拉的股價就是高的離譜跟那些其他的造車比如什麼奔馳寶馬這些公司來比完全就沒有邏輯於是就開始建倉去做空特斯拉經常在採訪當中就大舉宣傳自己的理論其實最開始那三四年還好特斯拉的股價也就是正常波動
他眾也不知道特斯拉他到底能造成個什麼樣1819年的時候特斯拉的產量開始指數級的增長人們對Elon Musk的質疑也一點點就被打消了其實一開始市場還沒反應過來的時候Channels就找老哥本來有機會撤退但是他不光沒撤在2019年底採訪的時候甚至還是一度宣揚特斯拉被嚴重高估結果我們都知道了你就說這個Channels那頭髮就是一把一把的掉從16年他開始建倉做空特斯拉到最後離場特斯拉一共翻了18倍
幸好他自己有個規矩就是任何一支個股在他的投資組合裡的比重都不能超過5%也是這條他自己的原則算是救了他讓他最後沒有虧得很慘但即使是這樣投資人的錢也都差不多快撤光了其實不光是Chanels特斯拉是有史以來被做空最多的一支股票只不過Chanels這裡邊是嚷嚷最大聲的那一個但你說這幫空頭也確實是倒黴讓他們碰上了Elon Musk據統計2020年做空特斯拉的這些空頭一共的虧損達到了400億美金
你想想這些基金經理到底掉了多少噸頭了。再比如說08年次貸危機之前，其實就有大量的做空機構已經看到了泡沫。就比如我們看那個電影《他空頭》裡邊，那個基金經理Michael Burry就開始通過各種金融衍生品，就CDS啊，跟銀行去做對賭。但你想這個資產一路漲，他就一路虧。他甚至最後就逼到沒轍了，禁止投資人撤資。每天就在那坑子，真的是度日如年啊。差一點就沒熬過來。不過最後幸好，
不是幸好對他來說是幸好次貸危機爆發了他這是屬於熬過來的但是還有那麼多做空的基金經理他們是沒熬過來的所以你看做空這個無底洞的屬性對於基金經理來講是非常可怕的空頭這活真的不是一般人能幹的一不小心就像Channels那樣一世英名毀於一旦
也就是因為這種單純做工的方法，風險實在是太高了。所以市場上像Channels這種專注於做空個股的對沖基金經理其實是非常少。其實做空在大多數情況下都會伴隨著對沖。就是說當我做空一個股票，我會再做多一個股票，或者說做多一個大盤的股指期貨。這種也是非常常見的一個對沖基金的策略，叫做long short strategy,多空策略。
就比如說我現在看跌老王奶茶店那我可以做空但是呢我又怕市場風漲對吧這時候我就可以去做多一個更穩健的比如說小林奶茶店那在這種情況下呢市場上假設這兩個股票同時漲或者同時跌那其實我的收益是不受影響的換句話說呢做多這邊做空這邊我相當於對沖掉了市場的系統風險有時候我們把它叫做Beta但是隻要我做多的那個小林奶茶店的股票表現好於我做空的老王奶茶店的股票我就賺錢
這我再順便提一嘴，其實有的時候這種多空策略並不是說我做空一個個股，我就一定要做多一個個股。有的時候我做空一個股票，我可以去做多大盤的股指期貨，就可以直接理解成你去做多大盤了。比如說我做空老二奶茶店，同時我去買美股大盤S&P的股指期貨，或者說我去做多小力奶茶店，然後我去做空美股大盤的股指期貨，一般都是這麼搭配著操作。稍微有點繞，但這個其實對沖基金裡面特別常見的一種操作。
這種多空策略裡面最經典的一個玩家就是對沖基金界的一個大佬叫做Julian Robertson,就是老羅。我們之前講悅哥的那期也講到過，他創辦的老虎基金從80年代開始就一直一朝鮮走遍天，就一直搞這個多空策略。15年間愣是把800萬的資產賺到了70個億，翻了將近1萬倍。老羅和他的老虎基金在90年代的時候那就是神一般的存在。
從1995年開始，隨著互聯網技術的高速發展，市面上就湧現出來了很多根本就不盈利也不賺錢就上市融資的互聯網公司，然後美股就進入到了一個直線上漲的模式。但是老羅這種非常穩健的投資人還是非常看基本面的，他就覺得這些互聯網企業的價值是被高估的，就開始大舉做空這些互聯網企業，然後同時去買入攬炒股來做對沖，其實就是剛剛我們說的那個long short strategy。
誰知道那些互聯網企業依舊是玩命持續地漲，就市場上當時的估值模型已經解釋不了那個價值了，所以大家又出來一些新的模型來去給它運用到互聯網企業，就比如說我要算一個客戶的價值，然後再看它給它一個增長指數，來給這些互聯網公司去估值。整個互聯網的產業就在急速膨脹。
這時候你想老羅他面臨的不光是因為這個股票上漲他做空的虧錢而且還面臨著來自投資者的質疑投資者就覺得你看互聯網行業是未來你怎麼能做空呢不行我得撤資
所以這時候即便老羅堅信自己是對的但面對著市場瘋狂的上漲一方面他得自己交保證金另一方面投資人給他瘋狂的撤資他的基金管理規模就從210億美金直線縮減到了7億美金2000年初的時候老羅是徹底撐不下去了這市場我是看不懂了就把自己的老虎基金給關了我不跟你們玩了
可是就在老虎基金關了之後的半年，市場上當時的資金已經全都吸引到股市去了，那這個積股傳花的遊戲就再也玩不下去了。所以股票就開始暴跌，納斯達克指數當時一年之內就跌了75%。大量的互聯網企業開始破產，這時候人們才意識到，之前的那些繁榮原來都是泡沫。這就是我們傳說當中經常聽說的互聯網泡沫，就是。com bubble。
老羅他其實是對的只可惜他不光得判斷對方向他還得找準時機才行其實挺多人覺得老羅在泡沫爆炸之前就提前撤出來了這是非常大的一個失誤但我個人其實還是挺佩服他的就一方面看著那個泡沫一點點的膨脹自己能在那撐那麼久更關鍵的是你想這麼傳奇的一個對沖基金經理在虧損那麼大的情況下就決定說金盆洗手我不幹了我撤出來不玩了
這其實是非常困難所以他最後也保住了他這個對沖基金大佬的江湖地位畢竟誰都知道你要判斷市場你要想判斷對方向這個事呢可能還有點把握但是你要想抓對時機那不能說不可能吧反正是比登天還難其實這些做空機構他們自己也明白肯定不能在這坐以待斃你整天燒香拜佛等著股票跌下來你得等到猴年馬月對吧就剛才我們說的大佬Channels他在自己做空一支股票的時候都對到處宣揚說你們看
Tesla這個估值被高估了，你們眼睛是瞎的嗎？但即使Channels那麼瘋狂地嚷嚷，市場也完全不鳥他。你想為什麼？因為特斯拉的那些數據，大家都是實打實在那看著。你們超商也只能說特斯拉未來會怎麼樣。但很大概率說到估值，其實是誰也說服不了誰的。估值這個東西就是公說公有理，婆說婆有理。好Channels說特斯拉價值被高估，就連Elon Musk都發推特說特斯拉價值被高估。但他股票還是一個勁往上漲，你就說拿他怎麼辦？所以做空機構就自己來了這麼一招，叫做出研究報告。
這種機構它就會找到那種真正有財務造假或者真正有欺詐行為的公司然後就會跟市場說大家別在那估值了這估值都沒有用這數據本身就是假的都是管理層編出來的管理層人品有問題這種情況下不管這個公司估值是高是低你數據要是造假這是非常嚴重的汙點這就是一個額外的負面信息所以股價必跌你看這不就穩了嗎股價一跌我這做空就賺錢了我就再也不用掉頭髮了
但事實是金融市場每天是有大量的新聞爆出來的你怎麼樣能讓市場相信你說的就是對的就是真的呢那就需要這些做空機構給出來一份非常詳實細緻的研究報告來證明說這個公司的財務是有問題的絕對就不是說三頁五頁紙隨便分析一下或者說I assume I propose這麼簡單了起碼就得二三十頁甚至上萬字的證明就羅列出來這個公司在造假的種種罪行只有這樣市場才會正眼看你
說到這兒，你腦子裡是不是想到了一家非常有名的公司？沒錯，就是渾水Modding Water Research
其實魂水它整個的創立包括做空的理念都源於一次偶然的機會魂水的創始人叫卡爾森布洛克卡爾森布洛克我們就叫他卡哥卡哥其實他也不是學金融的他是個法學的博士在中國待著也經歷了創業的失敗卡哥他爸是個股票經紀人當時2010年的時候他爸就看到了一個叫東方紙業的公司在美股借客上市了這個公司財報做的很漂亮年數能達到1億美金他爸就心思是發現了這麼好的一個寶貝我想大量買入這個股票
正好兒子不在中國而且這個公司是個造紙廠這個模式看著也很好理解所以他就想讓33歲的兒子就是卡哥到這個造紙廠去看看情況順便也當鍛煉鍛煉兒子卡哥挺有意思的估計他小時候可能是那種福爾摩斯看多了本來是想去暗訪
他大張旗鼓的找了一個美國記者去聯繫這個東方紙頁，然後自己就偽裝成這個美國記者的中文翻譯。然後這兩個人就以一個外媒想去採訪報導東方紙頁的形象進去了。進去之後，這領導帶著一頓參觀，他們就參觀了工廠，參觀了生產線，錄了一堆影像資料。
不看不要緊一看卡格發現這個東方紙頁真的是破爛不堪根本不像財報上寫的那麼厲害廠房設備都是上個世紀90年代你看這個是他們當時在東方紙頁拍下來的照片而這個是東方紙頁競爭對手的一個照片你看這一筆
他還發現東方紙業號稱價值230萬美金的回收紙板實際上就是一堆露天放著都被泡潑了的廢紙殼而且根據他們的財務測算按道理講東方紙業這個體量的公司每天應該是有上百輛的卡車進進出出
但是卡哥就看到場子前面就有一條只能單行的破土路兩個人在那蹲點蹲了半個小時就看見一輛車一直停在那個門口而且卡哥就非常確信即使是那輛車都可能是東方紙也放在那給我們裝模作樣看的卡哥一看這麼個公司哪能投資呀老八你趕緊停住這個公司不光不能投資我們要做空
於是他們就真的做空了東方紙業還在2010年6月底的時候發佈了一個30多頁的報告一五一十的把他們發現都揭露出來報告裡邊就說據估算08年的時候東方紙業的營業額誇大了27倍09年的時候營業額誇大了40倍當然渾水也公開表明他們做空了東方紙業最開始市場只是小幅的下跌就跌了10%因為畢竟東方紙業也不是什麼能掀起波瀾的大公司那時候渾水也不是那麼有名大家對這個報告也是半信半疑
但後來隨著媒體的傳播這事兒一點點發酵在接下來的兩天東方紙業就跌了50%渾水面對著大家各種的質疑和問題一個月內發表了八次報告證明自己的這些觀點是對的在接下來的幾年裡東方紙業的股票就持續下跌
憑藉著這個事讓Carson Block和渾水在這個圈裡就小有名氣了之後他們就接著這麼搞2010年11月的時候就爆料並且做空了綠諾國際之後綠諾國際承認造假並且退市11年2月的時候爆料了中國高速頻道後來中國高速頻道也退市了
包括最近的瑞幸咖啡反正他們的報告是寫的越來越專業越來越詳細基本上就是一招先先深度的秘密走訪然後財務調查找到做空的目標公司之後做空發報告看到股價跌撈錢走人類似的做空公司還有之前我們講Nikola的時候說的那個Hindenburg Research他們也是同樣的套路
所以你發現沒有這些靠研究出報告做空的公司你與其說他們是個金融公司不如說他們是個調查公司就專去找市場上那種有份的蛋這種方法你聽起來也覺得非常合理非常聰明對社會也有幫助其實就是清理那些造假欺詐的害群之馬打擊金融圈這種圈錢的風氣所以其實對那些安分守己踏踏實實做事的公司反而是個好事
可是問題就是這些公司他也不是包青天整天就想著為民除害作為一個作風機構他肯定是想從中獲利的找這種明目張膽的騙人公司雖說很理想但其實也不是那麼好找的就像卡哥自己就說過他找這些公司要有三大特徵就是3LLargeLiquid還有Lying就是大的流動性好的又存在欺詐首先為什麼要大的你想體量足夠大才能賺上錢對吧要不是這個公司花了那麼長時間去做各種研究然後做空然後宣傳出來股票就算跌了賺個三五萬
你說這時間多話不來，為什麼要流動性好呢？因為流動性好我才能把股票借進來然後賣出去對吧？咱剛才也聊到了，借股票它是有成本的，這個成本就取決於市場上的供給需求。如果這個股票長期都有人願意持有，比如說像蘋果這種公司，那你把它借進來做空的成本就很低，大概年化利率在0.25%。那像特斯拉這種做空的需求很高的，這個借股票的成本就會高一些，大概是2.5%。再比如說像2021年年初那個華爾街和韭菜大戰，那個GME不是被大量做空嗎？
那時候做空的需求就非常高當時借GME的利率達到了將近80%偶爾的時候還會超過100%就是說這個股票你借進來做空一年就哪怕這個股票最後跌到零你都一點不賺錢這就是為什麼卡哥說他第二個L就是一定要找那種流動性好的第三個L叫Lying存在欺詐但是你想要找個存在欺詐的公司肯定也不是那麼好找就意味著說你得是全世界第一個發現這家公司有問題
隨著想找有問題公司的做空機構或研究機構越來越多找到這個公司的難度也就越來越大這一點和前面那兩點又是衝突的因為那種越大流動性越好的公司它存在欺詐行為的概率其實是越低的這就是為什麼像渾水這種靠研究靠挖料來做空的機構其實他們的做空對象是非常有限的而且體量也是非常有限的就比如說根據渾水它之前向證監會提的一個報告他們的管理規模其實只有2.6億美金
員工才只有8個2.6億美金是什麼概念那在華爾街裡就是個小樓樓但其實他們在做空機構裡已經算是非常有知名度的像渾水這種管理規模也不是很大他們找一個體量沒那麼大的公司做空按理講也不是個難事但事實上並不是這樣了所以你經常看渾水他發布報告的時候也說我們有理由懷疑不啦不啦不啦或者說我們嚴重懷疑或者我們有理由相信但是他們背後也沒有一個特別特別確鑿的證據他當時像做空新東方做空安踏都也有那麼點連拆帶蒙的意思
所以你看這些做空公司平時吆喝的比誰都想那也是因為業務需要你要真正看他們在資本市場上的體量其實是微乎其微的像我們之前講的那個做空的大佬Channels他的資產差不多在10億美金管理規模最大的時候也就60億美金但這已經是做空機構裡面非常非常知名的了你說巴菲特那個資產是多少將近3000億美金
比如說整個美股市場裡大概有3%到5%的股票是被做空的。這裡面大多數其實都是像我們一開始說的老虎基金那種搞的那種多空策略就是long short strategy。真正像渾水這種就逮著一個然後去做空的這種情況是非常少的。這就是為什麼有人問巴菲特說你如何看待做空的時候。巴菲特就說
意思就是說做空這對於我們公司來講那就是個蒼蠅腿這麼看來單純做空確實也搞不大資本大佬也不屑於搞這些什麼去當偵探做調查但是有一種做空手法是大佬專屬的就是資本攻擊
當這些資本大佬感覺到市場上某一種資產的價值被高估了而且他感覺可能很多人都有同感但是出於某種原因這個資產的價格一直在高位的時候大佬就可以直接用海量的資本去戳破這種市場的幻象跟大家一起說說來大家跟我一起賣所以他們一般會通過大量的資本給這個資產一個原始的向下推動力當市場上發現有人開始帶頭了資產開始暴跌了
他們自己也會反思，你說原來這價格是不是太高了，之前的估值是不是太離譜了，那我也趕緊跟著賣吧，跟著大佬有肉吃。那如果說在市場上能得到足夠多的強反饋，那就會強行的把這個資產拉回到一個合理的價格區間，換句話說就是一個很好的回調機制。不過這些都是資本空頭進攻的一個理論支持，說它給市場起到了多麼多麼好的作用。但是畢竟大家都是非理性的，事實上你也不可能就回調到一個真正那麼合理的區間，因為大家其實也都會恐慌，
所以有的時候就會引發一些踩踏事件加劇市場的波動暴跌甚至引發金融危機這也是為什麼很多空頭都非常招罵的一個原因就小林經常說金融其實本質就是信用就是市場對你的信心就比如說一個公司你把這個信心給到位了信用給足了就算他有點小毛病扶著扶著就健康了反過來呢如果你強行打壓信心你說這個公司本來就走的不太穩你還上去給人踹一腳那很可能就造成這個公司一蹶不振
總結下來，市場覺得你行你就行，不行也行。市場覺得你不行你就不行，行也不行。
一旦有資本的空頭對你大肆進攻那意思就是指著你鼻子說你不行那對這家公司的市場信心是毀滅性的打擊的這種情況是很不利於市場的穩定的所以很多國家在有金融危機或者金融危機已經發生的時候是禁止這種做空行為的其實就是怕這些資本攻擊帶來一些額外的不必要的震盪和波動說資本攻擊我就舉兩個人大家可以想到誰打在公屏上看大家跟我想的一不一樣首先第一個利弗摩爾Jesse Livermore
第二個我猜大家會想到索羅斯利弗摩爾就是那個傳奇的大空頭我們之前專門講過一期他的視頻你要是看完這個可以再回去重溫一下應該能有新的收穫他在1929年的時候通過一百多個經紀人開始偷偷的大量做空美股這種資本攻擊市場上根本就頂不住股價就開始暴跌間接的就導致了美股大崩盤還有當時美國歷史上最大的一次大蕭條
當然利弗摩爾從中間賺了一億多美金也算是發了個國難財所以這個事其實是被很多人詬病的索羅斯這邊金融大鱷成名之作就是92年做空英鎊不過今天我們討論比較多的都是做空股票做空外匯和做空股票其實是兩個概念因為做空外匯的時候你做空一個貨幣其實相當於你變相做多了另一個貨幣比如說你做空Dollar Yen其實你在做空美元的同時同時在做多日元
它永遠是一個雙向對稱的關係就和我們直接做空股票不一樣所以說索羅斯這個雖然我們叫它做空英鎊但它其實跟做多做空我個人感覺關係沒那麼大屬於比較純粹的資本攻擊但確實很有意思很精彩大家如果感興趣可以留言評論告訴我考慮考慮之後可以出一期其實咱們今天已經說的夠多但是我之前不開始就說了嗎這想法粗粗粗粗粗就出來了所以我們接著深挖一層既然有資本攻擊就會有什麼呢對了資本反擊
做工呢就是有人看跌一個股票那在做工的同時其實是會伴隨著非常強烈的資本反擊因為總有人不希望這個股票跌你看都有誰啊比如說股東對吧股票的持有者他們肯定希望股票漲公司的管理層肯定希望股票漲還有誰啊勸商做事商其實理論上股票漲跌對他們無所謂但他們希望市場活躍因為活躍他們就越賺錢
那一般什麼時候活躍？肯定是股票走強，大家都高高興地在那賣的時候最活躍。所以這些勸商做事商，他們也希望股票漲。還有誰？像媒體、投行、研究機構。這些機構其實理論上講，你感覺應該是中立的，對吧？我就發發言報。但問題就是呢，這些機構其實很容易被隱性收買的。所以總的來說，多多少少會有點報喜不報憂。整個市場上，只有做空機構，他們是堅定不移地站在大家的對立面，希望股票跌。你就說他們這個小小的人群，要面臨著多大的壓力。
那麼大量的人都希望股票價格往上漲就會通過各種方式去給股價一些正向的激勵就比如說巴菲特老爺子曾經就這麼說過
那你說一旦你要做空如果你不能拿出點實錘來那對面一操場的人就挑出來給你群毆了所以對於做空方來講你要麼得有足夠多的料要麼就得有足夠多的彈藥才能堅持下去跟那一操場的人對抗來 給大家講一個前兩年鬧得沸沸揚揚的資本圈做空和資本反擊之間的博弈
有個兌充基金大佬Bill Ackman,比爾·阿克曼，我們就把他叫做阿格。阿格非常厲害，2015年管理的規模就達到了160億美金。2013年他發現了這麼一個公司叫做Herbalife Nutrition,是個賣保健品的公司。阿格就發現這個公司從來不打廣告，周圍也很少有人聽說，但是它的年銷售額有48億美金。
這是怎麼回事呢？經過調查他就發現，Herbalife用了這麼一套營銷手法，就是任何一個人都可以成為這個品牌的一個獨立銷售。你可以以一個折扣價買產品，然後你也可以去賣他們的產品，賣出去就能拿提成。這聽著都很正常，但是還有一條就不一樣了，就是你可以拉別人成為你的下限，然後你的下限如果賣出去，你也能拿提成。這種營銷模式有一個專業的名字叫做Multi-Level Marketing,就是多層次營銷。
是不是有點像傳銷傳銷不也是一層一層拉下線嗎但其實本身多層次行銷傳銷他們的界線就挺模糊的其實最後就是看你這個產品是不是真正賣到消費者的手裡如果是賣到消費者手裡那你可以把它叫做多層次行銷但你要是這麼一層一層就一直從你的下線裡邊賺錢那這就有點傳銷了對吧
阿哥經過調查他就篤定ErboLife這一套就是傳銷就開始大舉做空大佬出手手筆就是不一樣一上來就做空十億美金你看這單單一個頭寸就已經相當於四五個渾水的體量了因為阿哥在市場裡還是非常有影響力的
所以他一說自己做空，ERBOLIFE立馬跌了40%。然後就像我們說的一樣，阿哥就去幹空頭該幹的事，開始大肆宣傳，花了三四千萬美金在各種媒體發報告，甚至還做了一個三百多頁的PPT,就在去分析ERBOLIFE早要去傳銷。本來按照阿哥的計劃，一個大佬帶頭，又有這麼多證據，PPT什麼的，大家就會一起口誅筆伐，然後股價就會下跌，監管局就會介入調查，然後公司可能就倒閉了，自己大賺一筆。
但誰知道這時候又來了一位攪局的也是一個大佬叫做Carl Icahn就叫勞坎吧勞坎一直都是以惡意收購名聞天下的他就特別擅長把那些看著不太行的公司收購進來然後進行一個重組勞坎看著阿哥開始做工ErboLife一上來就是10億美金的頭寸就開始要跟阿哥對著幹大手筆的買入讓這股價一天就暴漲了20%然後自己也開始去宣傳基本上就跟大家說
達哥其實他就是個騙子他就是做空為了自己賺錢然後開始搞出來了這麼一套你就看著兩個億萬級別的大佬在這開始嘴砲打嘴戰大家就在邊上吃瓜也是津津樂道但你看這個市場的表現你就知道民眾似乎還是更相信資本家是罪惡的這個言論就基本上是往勞坎這邊站隊的你就看那個股價就持續的震盪當中微微上漲14年的時候美國有一個官方的調查機構叫FPC就是聯邦貿易委員會他就出來開始調查erbo life了
調查了兩年之後終於出結果FTC對ErboLife罰款了兩億美金並且宣佈要對它的銷售模式進行整改還有一堆經濟上的懲罰那你看啊又罰款了對吧又勒令整改了這一聽好像看著像是阿哥贏了對吧但事實還真不是要不說大佬真的是很厲害這個新聞一出兩邊嘴炮還是照打不誤阿哥這邊就說你看罰款了吧得了吧有問題吧我贏了吧傳銷了吧那勞坎這邊呢就說你看不就罰了這麼點錢嗎那FTC也沒說它是傳銷啊你說的不對吧
那你看這股市吧有時候你也說不上來為什麼就看這個股票短暫震盪之後突然就開始漲起來了2017年直接漲了51%這麼個漲法對阿哥這個空頭來說那不就是無底洞嗎我們之前說過它是無限的損失對吧所以面臨這種情況當時阿哥也是迫不得已不得不清空了自己的倉位開始去改買看跌期權了沒想到這股票還是一路飆升最後不得不期權也不要了就這麼暗暗的離場了就這樣在勞砍的阻截下阿哥虧了有10億美金你就說說這是多慘
好啊 咱們現在已經越聊越深入了但是剛才這個故事裡我其實刻意忽略了一個非常重要的核心邏輯你說為什麼老坎在明知道阿哥已經赤字十億美金做空的情況下非要衝進去和他作對呢你說是不是吃飽了撐的非要找一個大佬跟他對著幹你說你要輸了怎麼辦 對吧
當然老坎心裡怎麼想的他也沒告訴我我只能通過我的經驗去分析一下其實我覺得吧如果阿哥這邊不做空老坎八成也不會去買什麼Herbalife他其實就是要跟阿哥對著幹這裡頭非常重要的一個原因就是軋空叫short squeeze
我們剛剛說當你做空一個股票的時候實際上你要去跟這個中介或證券公司把股票借回來那證券公司就得保證你有借有還之後得把股票給還回來才行那他就得讓你交保證金就是margin你看老坎知道有人做空了10億美金的頭寸那這時候如果他大量做多會發生什麼股價就會往上漲短期內阿哥就會虧錢對吧他虧錢
中介就會讓他交保證金如果這個股價一直漲那阿哥就得一直補補到有一天他自己補不齊了就會被被迫清倉那這時候清倉他會幹什麼就會把那些ErboLive的股票再給買回來這麼大頭寸的買入就會讓ErboLive的股價直線上漲這種由於被迫清倉而導致股價飛漲其實就是short squeeze 軋空這時候勞坎不是做多嗎他就可以從中間大賺一筆
但我們知道阿哥是很有錢的，他的底子還是很厚的。所以對於勞坎來講，就算我沒有辦法一擊致命，我也可以這麼一直拖下去。因為剛才我們說做空要借股票，借股票本身就是有成本的。那像阿哥10億美金這麼大的頭寸，其實成本是非常高的。時間越長他虧的就越多，所以拖著拖著他可能就承不下去了。而勞坎他做多ErboLife,
最多就是這個股票跌到零那它賠的也就是賠11美金但是如果一旦形成了瓦空的局面它賺的可就不值百分之百這個就是勞坎的如意算盤你問我為什麼是這麼想的其實那時候勞坎已經是Erbolife的第一大股東了也在董事會裡頭
但是後來阿哥一宣佈自己撤了不玩了老坎立馬就退出董事會把自己的倉庫也都清空了所以很明顯他對Urban Life也沒什麼興趣八成就是想通過軋空把阿哥逼到牆角然後自己賺錢怎麼樣這個邏輯是不是分析出那麼點意思了我跟你說說真正的軋空這個路子能有多野咱們把時間倒回到1901年
那時候美國有一家鐵路公司叫做Northern Pacific Railway當然是什麼公司也不重要然後有兩個人你也不用知道是誰也不重要這兩個人就想爭奪這家公司的控制權就在1901年的三四月份開始大量的買入公司股票把股價從原來的20塊錢一直拉高到130塊錢
這時候就有一堆不明真相的交易員一看這股價虛高那我得趕緊做空誰知道這兩個人越爭越起勁一個勁的買股票把這股價又抬到150、180、200這時候這些空頭一看這麼個價值就想趕緊清倉理場清倉理場他就把股票買回來幹著說就發現這兩個人在爭奪控制權誰也不賣這個股票市場上的股票被這兩個人買光了根本就買不回來但是空頭們就更慌了就搶著去買就把這價格又往上抬就看這股價從200、300、500、800最後直接漲到了1000
但是不管這股價長得多高他們都買不進來這已經是最極致的軋空了所以對這些空頭來講它的賬面上就有著巨額的虧損這時候中介就會讓他們交保證金他們也拿不出來更多保證金了所以中介沒辦法就把這些人其他的股票給賣瞭然後來補保證金這一賣可好這嘩啦啦的賣就一度引發了整個大盤子踩踏事件這就是1901大恐慌Panic of 1901
好在這倆人也意識到了事情的嚴重性就決定咱倆現在都別爭了咱們放那空頭一馬就以165美金把這股票賣給那些空頭這下市場才逐漸的平靜了下來當然即使沒有1000塊錢那麼可怕165美金也足以讓這些空頭血虧所以你看這兩個人在那爭奪控制權神仙打架還順便割了一幫空頭的韭菜是不是還挺神奇的
其實類似於這種的軋空事件在市場上經常會上演，這種操控市場的玩法聽起來好像是非常刺激，但是它對市場的穩定性是有著很大程度的負面影響，因為它已經不是你在那理性的去考慮一個估值的高低，而是純粹的被迫和恐慌。
比如說剛剛我們提到老羅的那個老虎基金他在互聯網泡沫的時候不是最後沒撐住被迫離場了嗎？如果你看那時候納斯達克指數你就發現在泡沫爆破之前有一波風漲很多人就懷疑這就是因為像老羅這種大空頭被打空才導致的這波風漲你看平時我們看這些大空頭有很多精彩的案例感覺賺了很多錢
但是今天我講了這麼多例子，其實很多都是這些空頭被踩的例子。當然我也不是故意挑他們這些例子，因為市場上的空頭確實很難做。你看看，就像我們剛剛分析的，它不僅要面臨有限的收益，無限的損失，面臨著市場上能做空的標的物本身就很有限，面臨著借股票高昂的成本，面臨著做多方管理層這邊種種抵抗的壓力，還要面臨著軋空的風險，還有一把一把要掉的頭髮。還有一點，就是我們一提到做空，很多人就覺得很邪惡，都恨得牙癢。
因為你想要是做多就算你有一點什麼資本操控畢竟股票漲大都賺錢整個市場是高高興興的股票要跌也是大家都賠錢所以從心理上感覺還能強一點但是你想要是空頭賺錢了那肯定是因為股價大跌這時候市場上那一操場的人就都不高興了所以你就會感覺他們就是在那站在別人的痛苦上割別人的肉這個呢也是這些空頭們要面臨的另一大成本就是道德壓力
吃錢你可能就大家嘴上罵一罵吐吐槽就那麼地兒了但從2021年之後可就不是這樣了年初的時候沸沸揚揚的華爾街和韭菜的多空大戰純粹就是因為這些散戶看不慣華爾街那幫空頭了就開始大舉買入像是AMC GME這種股票就我完全也不管你估值完全不管我自己賠不賠我就是要幹你就逼得很多空頭像Melvin Capital這種2021年1月就血虧50%光GME這一個股票就讓那些空頭們虧了910億美金
這個事已經完全可以載入教科書了所以你看啊這些空頭太猖獗的時候整個市場都會起來反抗
累死我了你現在是不感謝自己已經滿腦子都是知識了其實你做空一家公司的方式有很多比如說你也可以做空期權做空股指期貨你可以搞一些什麼equity swap就是股票掉期甚至一些更誇張的什麼CDS信用違約互換等等等等但這些很多都比較豎理而且一般人也買不到所以今天我們講的還都是做空股票這一塊一開始做空聽著很刺激但是這裡邊那麼多坑那麼多潛在風險這就是很多人一般人都不敢碰就連很多專業的機構投資者也都是不敢做空的
這也是為什麼我們平時聽說很多共同基金保險、養老金這種大多數都是不允許做空的因為這都是普通群眾的續命錢對吧誰也經不起基金經理這麼個玩法當然也是因為我們剛才講的那麼多做空的特點才產生了這麼多有意思的故事從理論上講做空可以幫助市場提高流動性可以幫助資產回到正確合理的價格區間但是咱們今天看了這麼多真實的故事你是不是發現在真正的金融市場裡遠不止這麼簡單
行吧，小蓮今天聊的也夠意思了，我感覺你應該也聽過癮了。不給個一見三臉好意思嗎？就先這樣了啊，bye!